es ist soweit
ich denke schon
jetzt bekommst den doch noch den
wohnungsschlüssel
ich wollte hier eigentlich mit dir
wohnen nicht allein
ich weiß ich bin so froh dass du meine
rin in unsere wohnung ist
du weißt ich will nicht einfach alle
zelte abbrechen und alles hinter mir
lassen und nach allem was mir passiert
ist brauche ich einfach ein bisschen
zeit für mich das kann ich verstehen
zumindest meinen kopf kann dass mein
herz etwas anderes jetzt werde nicht
sentimental
ich sage nur was ich empfinde
lasst uns unsere auszeit nutzen ich sehe
meine familie wieder und gestaltet mit
der band durch und für mich kommt immer
nach brasilien
soll ich dich nicht doch zum flughafen
bringen
nein ich erkenne keinen reis noch
freiwillig ab
länger sechs monate geht ähnlich
dann brauche ich dich hier als
patentante ist es nicht du kannst doch
sein
es ist dort ganz sicher ich werde dich
vermissen ich dich noch viel mehr ganz
unten drunter kann man sich finden hier
für dich du immer deine kleine deutscher
satz familie längst ein älteres paar
alles gute trennung
du kommst bestimmt wieder in schutz
natürlich aber ich weiß nicht wie es
dann weitergeht
zu tun einfach einen engen kontakt und
lassen uns die aktivitäten von alexei
ganz auf brasilien aushalten
nach vorne schon
entschuldigung
brauchen sie ein taxi mag was machst du
hier machst du nicht arbeiten
es gibt wichtigeres taxi fahren
nein
dich
mag ich muss zum flughafen
du bist nicht wieso
ich liebe dich
komm zurück zu mir